[Música]
é em qualquer coleção a apresentação
conta uma história bem rápida resumindo
praticamente porque o interesse por
jogos eu chamei muitos jogos quando eu
era criança eu sempre sonhei em
trabalhar por isso digo sempre que
realmente contra mim não tinha o mesmo
existe essa vontade é com o primeiro
ataque que não vou por aí e que eu
também poderia jogar então isso surgiu e
comercializado não consigo fazer isto é
e será que ela acabou sendo aqui de
sergipe as possibilidades que eu tenho
acadêmicas mesmo de conquistar essa é a
noção de que os assuntos do momento
jogos elas não muito distantes neoci eu
quisesse trabalhar com jovens a estudar
jovem quiser ir para são paulo para o
sudeste do país acredita também no
sudeste sul e não conheceria a pensar em
como é que eu consigo fazer isso a
primeira coisa que eu tinha é que pára
de trabalhar com jogos eu saísse do
programa
a primeira coisa todo mundo pensa que
sabe programa serra que escolheu a
verdade então
estudei no colégio vai passar na
universidade ou faculdade de ciência da
computação da universidade federal a 103
desisti porque porque eu percebi na
época trabalhava em um outro outro
empreendimento meu cultura japonesa
aqui em sergipe e que eu percebi que eu
tenho um desejo também além de trabalhar
com jogos em aprender algo que eu
realmente gostava era apaixonada de
fazer então mudei o caminho é o seguinte
frente em pensar vou começar a seguir
essa idéia que eu tenho quero fazer de
trabalhar um pouco com a área das idéias
na área das pessoas para que daqui para
frente depois que eu faço para esse
desafio eu pudesse investir nessa
iniciativa minha de trabalhar com os
jogos foi entre planos rapidamente e
foquei no na indústria na quando
inspirados que foi lá a indústria das
idéias
justamente por essa e direcionamento
afinado com o projeto da avenida ricardo
brandão que está é um projecto preto
então está uma área que eu ia começar a
aplicar esse conhecimento dela
foi então que me formei universitário da
universidade de oregon e chegou o
momento em 2015
não faz muito tempo isso é que eu estava
o mário vai ficar agora eu quero fazer
algo que seja nenhum eu comecei a
estudar as idéias eu comecei é e
empreendendo digamos assim nessa nesse
conhecimento acadêmico mas eu queria
ainda trazer alguma coisa porque era o
momento certo depois da formação diego
lessa a se esse sonho foi perguntar o
que eu não posso surpreender
eu queria saber que ia sair do negócio
interessante é também mas eu queria
fazer algo que realmente me dessa lesão
e acordar todos os dias e olha que eu
trabalhar com isso aqui sempre foi o que
eu tenho ouvido na minha vida né
em seis jogos pode ser só que eu não sei
não há nem sou designer é na estratégia
de pesquisa então quando eu consigo
fazer algo que seja legal que as pessoas
que viram como é possível entrar nessa
área
foi então que comecei o imóvel
eu percebi que existe uma coisa muito
presente existem diversas outras pessoas
como eu que possuiu skills com sua
habilidade para poder aplicar
o projeto é que elas também não conhecia
outras pessoas que podiam ajudar a
contribuir pra isso eu percebi diferente
do meu primeiro pensamento que para
desenvolver um projeto no orçamento
seria problema
isso diversas outras áreas de videogame
como qualquer desenvolvimento global do
produto o marketing com design com
programação como eu falei mas também a
parte de mídia a partir de jornalismo
dessa tudo isso compõe por meio do
projeto
só que as pessoas precisam trabalhar
juntos para desenvolver os projetos
então foi perceber o efeito ou pessoa x
na universidade y que tem habilidade mas
que não conhece uma pessoa que pode ter
contabilidade então colômbia no final
foi criado justamente com o intuito de
ser a marca que vai reunir essas frentes
de projetos pudessem desenvolver ea
entre eles a mesquita é criar muito
perdido ele fique três objetivos que
pensar rápido mil pessoas
capacitar mentes e desenvolvendo jogos
não adianta gentili pessoas pra poder
crianças tomaram cerveja falar sobre
desenvolvimento de jogos se elas não se
capacitando agentes a passarela porque o
nosso mercado precisa se desenvolver
aqui pra gente desenvolva também não
adianta fazer só o curso se eu tô
conseguindo pegar essa comunidade e
fazendo com que se criem produtos por
isso os três objetivos eles são
complementares disse
a gente vê as pessoas para que elas
conheçam a gente capacitá los para que
elas tenham a capacidade de desenvolver
projetos ea gente envolvem dos jogos
desenvolvendo projetos
foi aí que a gente começou a deus nós
primeiros aprendizados
eu acreditava que se o 10 para as
pessoas
a estrutura de trabalho a rotina de
trabalho a assessoria jurídica sobre
neymar do santos e estruturar sua base
as pessoas que quiserem focado na parte
técnica
silva era administrador então ele vai
vencer no estado o projeto não se
preocupar com o resto a gente se
preocupa com isso tudo isso dentro de um
contrato de risco
tudo der certo tudo bem a disputa é
cerrado nem pena era uma proposta de
seguir esse sonho esse mesmo sonho e
compartilhar com todos nós de poder ter
uma estrutura que fazer com que o
projeto acontecesse porém não funciona
assim
infelizmente a gente estava começando
lidando com um grupo de universitários e
pessoas que realmente estão muito
empolgados em fazer umas fazer os
projetos possuem outras prioridades na
vida acabam tratando uma obra original
com o segundo da coisa a se fazer
enquanto podia entregar as metas ele
pensou cada médico consegue montar isso
aí fazer algo que realmente engate as
pessoas para que elas executam trabalhos
e produtos comecem a nascer a gente
parando a gente pensou que a gente
pensou no nosso objetivo e criamos três
iniciativas para cada um deles
o primeiro objetivo foi o game que é um
evento é esse evento vai transmitir
jogos onde um evento criado apenas para
unir as pessoas
então pessoas confraternizarem pessoas
conhecerem
logo depois a gente vê o connor jack a
nossa gente é porque não sabe que é um
evento a gente confira tudo de pessoas
com habilidades diferentes durante um
período de 36 a 48 horas para
desenvolver o jogo nesse período
então ela se conhece um gay elas
trabalham juntas lá o dinheiro e uma
coisas a gente capacitada elas concurso
de um shopping que são de graça ou até
mesmo cursos longo prazo são pagos em
parceria com outras iniciativas como
universidades é história de como o que é
vital
então a gente tem uma iniciativa para
cada objetivo nosso a gente pegou nosso
objetivo e transformamos exigências
diferentes coisas práticas sejam
executados dentro dessas enzimas a gente
conseguiu desenvolver mais nos jogos em
menos de um ano é justamente porque a
gente encontre outras pessoas essa
estrutura e elas abraçaram a idéia
é algo rápido ela alcançasse o resultado
daquela freguesia de glória adorando
está deixando de ser uma empresa para
ser mais ou menos com um colector entre
essas partes desses todos esses jogos
que foram desenvolvidos eles são os 71
anos é e as pessoas que fizeram parte
deles o lixão criam seus próprios
estudos se conectar através de nossas
iniciativas
então de uma certa forma a gente
conseguiu contribuir para que esse fato
pudesse acontecer mas ainda temos muito
a melhorar
não acredito que a ciência não é quesito
de objetivos que a gente tinha
prioritariamente mas a gente pensa na
obra da nova ponte nova uma empresa e
essa empresa não estava funcionando em
questão de negócio causa dessa estranha
da canção objetivo e ainda assim não
está dando certo em gestão de negócios
porque o nosso modelo no estado
funcional foi a gente olhou em volta
novamente ea gente pessoa com fazemos
para resolver esse problema
e aí hoje o laboratório é e acabou se
tornando o estúdio a gente falou que
pensou por que a gente faz isso tomar
todas as atitudes em prol de 16 jogos
resposta simples poderia fazer jogos
isso nosso principal objetivo
não porque a gente está ajudando as
pessoas a fazer jogos e nós não estamos
nos jogos nós queremos nós jogos e
queremos dar às pessoas a fazerem jogos
eu só tentei trazer essa imprensa da
unidade ele consegue construir
foi aqui hoje insistiu que nós somos um
estúdio estamos trabalhando o nosso
primeiro projeto
infelizmente não mudaram a etapa eu
possa mostrar a vocês mas que ele está
em desenvolvimento com toda estrutura
profissional é é que nós desenvolvemos
esse período de um ano de aprendizado
e foi justamente isso as mudanças a
gente quis fazer trazer um laboratório
para a gente consegue continuar
fomentando o mercado local e até mesmo
o autor precisa do orçamento ações aí
mas a nossa casa mas também porque a
gente consegue conseguisse tocar para
frente essa idéia é que a gente quer
fazer
então o pessoal ao ensaio final para
deixar para vocês em um laboratório
independente depois dos problemas que a
gente tenha passado de todos os
resultados que a gente é alcançado uma
coisa foi muito importante
eu precisei tomar a primeira o primeiro
passo é independente sobre as cobras lá
independente se eu soubesse ilustrar
alguma coisa até mesmo fazer outras
questões técnicas direcionadas aos
jovens um pouco problemático dizendo uma
iniciativa e essa iniciativa me trouxe
muitas oportunidades
muitos contatos próprio fato está aqui
hoje compartilham esse conhecimento é
resultado de um primeiro passo que foi
dado há mais de um ano atrás
então eu quero dizer para vocês o
seguinte quem dependem das iniciativas
que vocês também na sua vida toma
iniciativas têm o primeiro passo
independente se você já não se preparar
mas quando você der um primeiro passo e
os riscos começaram a acontecer você
sair dessa zona de conforto você falar
agora eu tenho esse papel a cumprir esse
objetivo o universo começa a trazer as
oportunidades a trazer as possibilidades
a trazer as pessoas e os contatos não
toma iniciativas
[Aplausos]